good afternoon
i'm celeste strike the president's
maiden america director
over the past year it's been my distinct
honor and privilege of setting up the
first ever made in america office
helping deliver on the president's
vision for a future that's made in all
of america by all of america's workers
the made in america office is working to
coordinate a whole of government
strategy to ensure that when the federal
government spends taxpayer dollars we
support
american workers and american firms
we're sending a clear signal to the
business community to drive new
investments create jobs and to fill gaps
in our critical supply chains
and we've gotten off to a great start
with the bipartisan infrastructure law
the biden harris administration and
congress are working together to make a
once in a generation investment in
building a better america
modernizing airports bridges and rail
ensuring communities have clean water
and affordable high-speed internet and
investing in the sustainable clean
energy industries we need to compete and
win in the 21st century
these investments will make our economy
stronger and more resilient with more
jobs more growth and more opportunities
for america's workers
our strategy is working businesses are
investing in american manufacturing at
historic rates and our economy added 423
000 manufacturing jobs since the
president came to office
a good example of this success is
siemens usa
siemens usa is a global leader in
innovative healthcare infrastructure
and energy technologies
employing 40 000 people serving
customers all over the united states
siemens is just one of many major
companies investing in the united states
meaning jobs for hard-working americans
at the helm of this corporation is
barbara humpton a woman who views the
true purpose of technology as expanding
what's humanly possible
barbara most recently served as
president and ceo of siemens government
technologies where she was the leading
integrator of siemens products and
services for federal agencies
she currently sits on the board of
directors for the national association
of manufacturers
and for these reasons it's my pleasure
to introduce barbara humpton president
and ceo of siemens usa corporation
[Applause]
thank you celeste and thank you mr
president for inviting us to the white
house for this announcement
and what better day than employee
appreciation day you can see on the
screens here we have employees from
pomona california as well as grand
prairie texas
and you know
and you know that for years the
questions about america's crumbling
infrastructure has been what if
instead of just maintaining what if we
really invested in the next century of
american growth and leadership
we now have the opportunity to answer
this question thanks to the bipartisan
infrastructure law
as the president said in his state of
the union address earlier this week
we're done talking about infrastructure
weeks now we're talking about an
infrastructure decade
and when we get to focus on today is not
just what we'll build
but who will build it over this next
decade
people like my colleagues joining us
today workers who support the industries
and create the infrastructure that form
the backbone of america's economy
our teams in pomona and grand prairie
develop electrical equipment powering
critical infrastructure systems
including electric vehicle chargers data
centers and factories today to meet the
growing demand and to support national
infrastructure projects siemens is
announcing our plans to invest 54
million into these manufacturing
facilities
additionally later this spring will
identify the location of a new ev
charging manufacturing hub to support
our goal to produce more than a million
ev chargers over the next four years
all told this footprint expansion just
this footprint expansion
it translates to nearly 300 new jobs and
we know there will be more jobs still to
come in our regional supply chains
folks a new era for manufacturing is now
taking shape in america think about what
we've experienced during the global
pandemic covet 19 affected everyone
everywhere but from the start the
response to it was local
we had to have readily available
production and in-demand supplies and as
we've continued to address supply
shortages of critical items everything
from ppe early in the pandemic to chips
more recently the future of industry
we're now seen is what i've been calling
glocal
we've seen how essential global
innovation can be
and it will continue so but as supply
chains have been disrupted and we've
also seen how important it is to be able
to establish local production
capabilities
we see that we can build resilience
against future disruptions
but that's not all
technology from automation to digital
tools to additive techniques like 3d
printing is strengthening the case for
investing in american manufacturing or
for globalization
it's strengthening the case for making
things in america for american customers
leveraging state-of-the-art technology
and being able to co-locate
manufacturing with research and
development
just like we're doing today as we
partner with national manufacturing
institutes in detroit chicago and
silicon valley
all of this leads to more resilient
supply chains
i'll add that when intel ceo pat
gelsinger was here in january to
announce plans for new u.s semiconductor
plants we heard pat voice his support
for funding the chips for america act to
boost u.s semiconductor production
and i'd like to join commerce secretary
raimondo and the president in supporting
targeted investments in research and
development and in industrial
modernization projects we're glad to see
bipartisan support for growing advanced
manufacturing in america at greater
speed and scale and we urge congress to
take action let's continue to work
together across the public and private
sectors to build this industrial base
and i'll say this we have some real work
cut out for us when it comes to
inspiring the next generation of workers
to join in what we're building
at siemens we're actively recruiting for
more than 2 400 jobs open jobs today
nationwide approximately a quarter of
our hiring demand is in manufacturing
where nationally there are currently
more than 800 000 job openings so i'm
looking forward to handing it over to
lonnie stevenson president of the
international brotherhood of electrical
workers in just a minute
but before i do i want to share one
final idea about how we build this
workforce because i really think a lot
of it comes down to addressing the myth
we hear so often that investments in
modern technology will relegate workers
to the sidelines
folks for the first time a human picked
up a rock and used it as a tool
tools and technology have elevated the
role of humans
and the future of manufacturing is no
different it's no different even as we
introduce tools which frankly i never
could have even dreamed of when i
started my career as a software
programmer in the
early 1980s
i mean we actually were using slide
rules back then
but today in grand prairie and pomona
they use our digital twin technology
that was instrumental in supporting
nasa's mars rover mission software that
combines the real and digital worlds and
in grand prairie they've also deployed
advanced robotics
yet what i saw when i last visited grand
prairie wasn't fear of an automated
future it was actually excitement
workers weren't being replaced a new
training program for technicians was
teaching them how to program robots
instead of being focused on repetitive
tasks workers were running multiple
machines they were programming the
delivery of parts for the next shift
multi-generational teams were working
together to increase product
quality safety and speed to market
so
as our infrastructure investment leads
to new orders that spark transformation
across american manufacturing we're not
going to automate people out of the
process no i promise you we will expand
what's humanly possible
we'll expand opportunities for people at
all stages of their lives their careers
and education to shape a future that's
more sustainable resilient
and equitable
mr president thank you so much for
bringing us here today and now i'd like
to introduce lonnie stevenson
[Applause]
you barbara and i've uh thank you mr
president
for the opportunity to be here today and
just let me say this before i get
started my remarks
president biden said
a year ago and he was talking about
bringing jobs back to the united states
and good paying manufacturing jobs and
more importantly he says union jobs and
that's what we're here we're here
working with our partnership the
partnership that we're so proud that we
have in the ibew with siemens
and see them following through having
the opportunity with the infrastructure
to be able to expand what they're doing
here across the country it's going to
mean job opportunities for our members
as they expand it means more
union jobs available in the united
states so thank you both barbara and
president biden for your commitment to
make this happen
you know
the ibew is the largest union of
electrical workers in all of north
america
the international brotherhood of
electrical workers is ready to work with
business and elected officials in
building a new clean energy economy and
a 21st century infrastructure
that's why i'm excited by siemens
announcement that it's investing in
america manufacturing to make sure that
the electrical equipment that will help
modernize and strengthen our industrial
and energy infrastructure while at the
same time putting us on the road to
clean energy future at the same time
not only will this equipment be made in
the usa
it will be union made as well
in supporting good-paying jobs for ibew
members that they can then support their
families and have you know comfort to
know they've got good good opportunities
for their them and their families
the bipartisan infrastructure act has
opened up new opportunities to invest in
clean energy generation and building the
parts that will modernize our roadways
bridges
transportation system
and the
and the energy grid which we're all part
of that as well
and it's all going to be done here at
home
today's announcement proves an action
that this groundbreaking legislation is
already helping support american jobs
and american manufacturing
investing in our infrastructure and
manufacturing industry in our also means
investing in skilled blue-collar
training
and the ibaw is proud to partner with
siemens in providing the pathways to
advanced manufacturing careers in in
this industry
union careers they won't just rebuild
our infrastructure but our middle class
as well
as i have been saying for years now
ibw members are ready and i've been
saying it for a long time we're ready to
get to work
and rebuilding our infrastructure
and growing a renewable building or
energy economy and we're excited to be
working with our industry partners such
as siemens and others and taking the
first steps towards a stronger more
competitive and cleaner economy
so again mr president i can't thank you
enough
and i want to say give a shout out to
our members in both california and and
texas they're the ones the backbone
they're the ones doing the heavy lifting
the work day in and day out
producing
for this country and making us a better
country because of it so thank you to
all them and next i have the really
distinct honor to represent our next
speaker
ibew member
johnny lee johnny i think you'll see
what you hear from him is dedicated he's
a hard worker he's very well respected
amongst his peers his workers and he
also understands that he wants to make
sure that siemens is also being you know
being able to move forward and as the
company and that they're successful as
well so please give a warm welcome to
johnny lee
good afternoon
my name is johnny lee
i stand before you as a proud member of
the ibew local 220 fort worth
a proud employee of the siemens grand
prairie facility and a living embodiment
of the american dream
when my parents fled communist vietnam
with nothing but the clothes on their
back and the hope of a better life
they never envisioned that one day their
son
would be introducing the president of
the united states
what they did know was the hope and
promise of america
the idea that with a little bit of hard
work everyone can succeed
through their support of my involvement
with my local union i am proud to say i
have found success in achieving that
dream
i built a life that i love
one filled with peace
pride
and the opportunity to serve others
as a shop steward and a vietnamese
interpreter within the plant i help my
union sisters and brothers on issues
that impact all of us
all while building infrastructure for a
better tomorrow
my story
and so many others of first generation
americans would not be possible without
the important pro-worker pro-union
policies that president biden and his
administration support
by investing in infrastructure and good
union jobs president biden is laying the
foundation for a future that will
support working families for generations
to come
a proud partner in future and the future
are companies like siemens
by investing millions in employee
training programs and workforce
development initiatives siemens is
creating a pathway to the middle class
for thousands of working families all
while solving the infrastructure
challenges of today and tomorrow
it's true that individual sacrifice and
hard work are central to the american
story but as my contribution shows the
american dream is also about a belief
and a greater good
an idea that when we work together
everyone can prosper
i am proud to be a part of that dream
it is now my distinct pleasure to
introduce to you
the president of the united states
[Applause]
[Music]
what johnny didn't tell you he's a break
dancer
but he's not going to do it on the stage
right now
before i begin officially today i want
to thank the maiden american director
celeste strait
i also want to acknowledge it's her
birthday and it's really tough turning
30 so be nice to him
happy birthday
[Applause]
and johnny thank you thanks for all your
co-workers i just had a chance to meet
before you all came in
and i want to thank barbara barbara
hampton siemens lonnie stevenson
president ibw one of my closest buddies
and he's been my friend for a long long
time
earlier this week in my state of the
union address i said there was something
happening in america
starting with historic economic recovery
that we're seeing right now and today
we've learned that in february
our economy created
678
000 new jobs
678 000 new jobs
over the course of my presidency our
economy has
now created
7.4 million jobs
more jobs created in a 13-month period
than any time ever before in our history
and we've learned that in february the
unemployment rate fell to 3.8 percent
down from 6.4 percent the day i took
office
and beginning in 2021
which is the fastest decline in
unemployment rate in recorded history
because of all of you
by the way before the american rescue
plan passed the congressional budget
office didn't project our unemployment
rate to hit 3.8 percent at any time
over the entire decade
americans are back to work
yes family budgets are still tight but a
lot of americans are getting paid checks
this year more than they got last year
and uh restoring the dignity of work
so they can show up at work with some
pride
you know job gains in february were
broad-based across sectors from
construction to retail to manufacturing
to leisure and hospitality
the decline in unemployment rate was
broad-based as well
the fact that unemployment rate among
workers without high school degrees fell
to 4.3 percent the lowest on record that
we've since been keeping records
4.3 percent
it's amazing
workers weekly earnings rose in february
the people in working class sectors like
transportation warehousing saw some of
the strongest wage gains
this is what it looks like to grow an
economy from the bottom up in the middle
out because of the progress we've made
in fighting covet americans can not only
get back to work but they can go to the
office and safely fill our great
downtown
cities again and bring you more commerce
with 75 percent of adult americans fully
vaccinated
and hospitalizations down by 77
most americans can remove their masks
return to work and move forward safely
today's news is a welcome reminder that
we're coming back stronger as a country
and as a people
you know uh
we've been through two of the hardest
years this nation has ever faced
the pandemic has been punished as many
of you know and some of you may know it
from a personal standpoint maybe you
lost someone in this process you got up
this morning and looked at an empty
chair
well it's been punishing but we're
coming back
and so many families are still
struggling though to make ends meet
because of inflation
i understand our top priority must be
getting prices under control
look
our economy roared back faster than most
predicted but the pandemic meant that
businesses had a hard time hiring enough
workers
to keep up and production in their
factories
the pandemic also
disrupted the global supply chains
factories when factories close it takes
longer to make goods and get them to the
warehouse and get them to the store and
prices go up let's take a look at cars
last year there weren't enough
semiconductors to make all the
automobiles people wanted to buy
they had a lot more money
in their savings accounts
and their paychecks but they weren't
able to go out and spend it on leisure
because of covid so what happened they
decided that they were purchasing
products like everything from homes to
automobiles to hard products
and the price of automobiles for example
went way up
more people seeking them and fewer being
made
and we have a choice
we have a choice the way to fight
inflation is to drive down wages and
make americans poorer
or have a better plan to fight inflation
lower costs and not your wages
the more semiconductors we make in
america and by the way they were
invented here in america the
semi-conductor was invented in america
when we went to the moon
and when we do that when we focused on
making sure that we make those again in
the united states of america so few are
being made
we make and we make a heck of a lot more
cars
and you bring prices down the supply
chain is filled
investment in america rebuilding roads
bridges airports ports
we invest in innovation in america
that's exactly what we're doing look as
a result we're seeing more jobs more
hope and we're also seeing something
else the rebirth of pride
the rebirth of pride there comes some
stamping products made in america
and we're seeing the revitalization of
american manufacturing
that's what i want to talk a little bit
about for the next few minutes
today companies are choosing to build
new factories
when just few years ago they would have
built them overseas they're investing
right here in america
on this very stage we were standing
before
intel the chairman of the board of intel
was here
he announced in a 20 billion dollar
investment
to build a semiconductor
semiconductor mega site outside columbus
ohio
creating 10 000 new good paying jobs
portion of them are the construction
jobs but the full-time jobs the average
salary in those places are going to be
135
000 a year
now if congress passes the bipartisan
innovation act
intel is ready to increase their
investment from 20 billion dollars to
100 billion dollars
you know as i said we invented the
semiconductor but we have been making
them in america for a long time we had
to import them we had to wait it costs
more and that's what i mean when i say
dealing with the supply chains
since i took office companies have
announced investments totally more than
100 billion dollars in electric vehicle
industry for the future
the iconic companies like ford gm
new electric vehicle production tesla
our nation's largest electric vehicle
manufacturer to innovate and invite and
inspire younger companies like rivien
building electric trucks
pro terra building electric buses
last month
the mp materials which operates only
rare earth the only rare earth mine in
the united states announced a 700
million dollar investment
by
2025
that will have fully demand it will have
have a fully domestic end-to-end supply
chain for the magnets that are used in
electric vehicle motors
wind turbines and defense systems
which invest in that money here in the
united states
and the union pacific railroad announced
the largest purchase of american-made
battery electric locomotives in history
and guess what they're built in western
pennsylvania
all told the economy created 423
000 new manufacturing jobs in america
paying decent salaries just since i
entered office
there's also a reason this is another
reason this happened
we're not waiting for others to
manufacture the products we invented
we know what to do we know how to
manufacture things in america today
that progress continues
i just had a chance to visit have a
viral tour of both the siemens
facilities one on pomona and the other
in grand prairie texas a chance to talk
with some of the ibw members working
there
because our infrastructure law provides
7.5 billion dollars 7.5 billion dollars
to build a national network of 500 000
electric vehicle charging stations
across america and it also provides 16.5
billion dollars to modernize our power
grid
how we move electricity across america
companies like seaman are investing here
in the united states of america
and you just heard from barbara
siemens is announcing a 54 million
dollar investment to upgrade and expand
those facilities in texas and california
that develop high-tech high-value
electrical equipment that is used in
electric circuitry switchboards electric
vehicles
chargers out on the highways and data
centers
this announcement alone is going to
create 300 new good paying cutting edge
manufacturing jobs
folks america's coming back it really is
in addition to siemens in addition
siemens will be building an entirely new
facility to make charging equipment for
electric vehicles
the location of that facility will be
announced later this year i don't know
where it is so don't ask
a lot of my colleagues in the congress
are going to be saying joe where's it
going to go i don't know
but it's going to be in america
and help us continue to grow our clean
energy economy
look folks
when i ran and got elected i said i
wanted to rebuild america this is what i
was talking about
and we want to see a lot more stories
like this one
so when the taxpayers dollars to rebuild
america when they're that's what they
are taxpayers dollars we're going to buy
american buying american products to
support american jobs and by the way
these are the best products in the world
the federal government spends about 600
billion dollars a year
in goods and services to fulfill its
responsibility to the american people
from the defense department to health
care to education and beyond
the fact in fact what's happening is the
federal government
is siemens largest customer for example
most people don't know there's been a
law on the books for almost a century
to make sure that your tax dollars
support american jobs and american
businesses
every administration says they're going
to use that that law
but when it comes time to make these
purchases
whether that's the deck of an aircraft
carry or a ventilation system in a
school the response often is from the
from the government we can't find an
american company so we need to issue a
waiver and buy the product that was made
overseas not by an american worker
so buy american became a hollow promise
my administration
buy america is a reality we've created a
made in american office in the white
house to oversee efforts
and you just heard from celeste who runs
that office
my first cabinet meeting i told everyone
that if their agency wants to issue a
waiver to purchase something for their
agency
and what they have responsibility for it
they don't have to use it
they
and they think they don't use american
company well guess what
they have to come to the white house
office and sit up and explain to me why
they have to post that request why they
have to do that
and they're going to have to post a
request publicly on our sites so
american manufacturers in business have
a chance to raise their hand and say no
no i can do that
here here here here i can do that my
shop in my town
today we're going even further i'm
announcing the biggest change in the buy
american act in 70 years
right now
if you're manufacturing a product that
gets purchased by the federal government
the law says that has to be
substantially all of that product should
be made in the united states
but because of loopholes over time you
know what substantially substantially
all means when i took office
if 55
is made in america it's substantially
all
to me
55 isn't substantially all it's slightly
over half
today we're issuing a rule
to raise the amount of domestic content
required to be considered made in
america from 55 percent to 75 percent
substantially all
is going to start meaning substantially
all
and today we're also announcing a new
framework for critical products where we
know we need stronger more resilient
domestic supply chains
we saw during the pandemic
that supply chain disruptions can put
american lives and lives because the
risk
you know when we when we we when we
needed the most we were short on mass
gowns gloves ventilation
and other essential health products we
had to buy abroad
so we're creating a new price preference
what this means is that if we're
identifying some product that is so
critical to our national security health
or resilience
that we're going to create rules that
allow us to pay a little more for them
if they're made in america
we're talking about things like
semiconductors some pharmaceutical
agreements advanced batteries among
other things
it's worth it for us to ensure that we
have a domestic capacity to protect us
from shortages and price spikes in the
future
and yes we're going to keep trading with
our allies and friends
and we're going to work with them to
ensure every single country can create
global
choke points for critical goods can't
have those joke points but we also need
a resilient supply chains of our own
so that we're never at the mercy of
other countries for critical goods ever
again
and by the way when i say buy america i
mean by all
america
i want to increase the share of federal
spending and goods and services that go
to small businesses in america the
backbone of our country
last year i released a plan to increase
the number of contacts
that go to small disadvantaged
businesses by 50
by 2025.
this means more contracts will go to
black brown native american women-owned
veteran zones small businesses
in every state and territory
in every industry from services to
manufacturing to agriculture
already we're seeing success
women-owned businesses have won
contracts to provide mass for the
government clothing for the marines
veteran-owned small businesses are now
producing specialty trucks and trailers
for the department of veterans affairs
and the army
we're seeing other buy american
successes which will allow us to make
synthetic rubber gloves in alabama
fibers that go into n95 mask in new
hampshire
shipping containers in maryland the list
goes on
and here's what it all adds up to
today
i'm placing a bet on america
everyone here is going to make sure that
it pays off everyone on this stage
what i say today what i've what we've
seen in the past months is more reason
why we need to reject the defeatist few
that the forces of automation and
globalization mean we can't have good
paying union jobs manufactured here in
america
our manufacturing future
our economic future our solutions to the
climate crisis they're all going to be
made in america
what that means to build a better
america
well it does we're going to build a
better america as a consequence so thank
you all very much and i thank my
colleagues for being here and i
understand a lot of siemens folks are in
the front row there too welcome and
thank you all in california and in texas
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you